when I was a kid
Aladdin was my favorite Disney movie I
felt like even though I liked Little
Mermaid and Beauty and the Beast this
was the first Disney movie for boys
it had action it had sore fights and had
llama it had flying around on magic
carpets it had monsters it had comedy it
had a lot of adult jokes that I actually
sort of understood it had kick-ass songs
it was just awesome but I will admit as
I get older that novelty seems to wear
off a bit
oh my Beauty and the Beast that gets
better and better as I get older I do
see more and more the flaws of Aladdin
okay well let's look at the story
Aladdin is a thief trying to get by in
the streets he comes across a princess
named Jasmine who's trying to get away
from the palace to make a life for her
but he gets captured by a sorcerer named
Jafar and gets manipulated into
searching for a magic lamp here he comes
across a flying carpet and of course the
genie do I even need to say who voiced
him hello Aladdin nice to have you on
the show can we call you al or maybe
just din how about lobbies sounds like a
boy come on like that so he goes back to
town using one of his wishes to turn
himself into a prince
this allows him the possibility to marry
the princess but Jafar won't let it
happen he tries to kill Aladdin and take
the lamp away so he can use the genie
for his own diabolical powers you get
your sword fight giant monsters action
comedy all the good stuff so what is it
about Aladdin that does or doesn't work
well a lot of the time it's sort of the
same thing Aladdin is very modern even
Agrabah looks much more like Vegas than
a dozen Arabian City of course Robin
Williams jokes well funny
I'll come from a way that current people
talk and even movies that haven't been
made by this time period if I didn't
even know what movies were back then so
there's a lot of breaking the fourth
wall jokes and of course a lot of
modern-day talk I'm in the mood dude
well most of it modern aladdin and
Jasmine though they don't quote as many
movie stars as Williams does still seem
out of their time period too they seem
more like Gen Xers than they do the
product of an Arabian village Jafar is
pretty cool and the Sultan is enjoyably
stupid but most of it doesn't seem to
take place once upon a time but more
around the time that maybe shrek lives
in fact yeah shrim probably stole a lot
from this movie didn't they so does that
make a light him bad necessarily if
anything it makes it unique it's a very
different take that Disney was trying to
do and apparently it really paid off the
jokes Robin Williams makes is funny and
despite the fact that it doesn't look
like Arabia it still looks great the
colors in this movie are just wonderful
as well as the lighting on top of that
what I think is really important is that
aladdin and Jasmine do have chemistry
yeah I know it's another three day
romance and then suddenly they get
married but you know what you believe
they're in love they do have
conversations that you talk about their
problems than they do try to help each
other out
okay it's not buting the bees but it
works okay the songs are still awesome
it's still Alan Macon and it's still
those incredibly catchy beats
at times some of the modern talking get
a little annoying like when Aladdin
tries to act cool or Gilbert Godfried
yell some more but I think it still has
the same Disney heart and it is very
entertaining so while I don't like it as
much as I did when I was a kid I still
do like it
there's still a lot of things to admire
a lot of things to laugh at and a lot of
things to hone after leaving the theater
as long as you know what you're getting
yourself into chances are you'll have a
pretty good time
Oh